[Music]
the longest war in american history is
set to end u.s troops will leave
afghanistan as nato forces prepared to
withdraw the final troops from
afghanistan in 2021 after two decades
the taliban began to advance rapidly
taking city after city province after
province their goal the capital couple
breaking news and taliban fighters have
arrived at the afghan capital kabul
the speed was remarkable not just to the
millions of afghans whose lives were
about to fundamentally change
but also across the world to governments
watching from their capitals and to
journalists like myself
sent a report i hear a lot of shouting
uh
coming down the road behind me in fact i
think it's a procession of uh
of the taliban
uh yes it is they're in their
xiaohuacanes they're led by a white flag
um and they're chanting as they go go
down i'm sky news chief correspondent
stuart ramsey and i was reporting with
my team from kabul when on august the
15th it fell to the taliban gunfire
followed by people running
police vehicles suddenly appearing on
the streets anti-missile systems firing
chaff into the air
chaos descended on kabul thousands fled
to the airport desperate to get out
western governments had promised
sanctuary to people who had helped their
efforts against the taliban but in the
chaos getting out became in itself
deadly
many had to make painful life-changing
decisions
and they all have their own story to
tell
they told me you were sonus in in here
your daughter's not in here and my wife
she was cried my doctor i lost my
daughter even now when i'm alone at home
and when i remember the airport in the
coming
even night time when i go to bed and i
couldn't sleep that time it was really
hard for us
over two weeks more than fifteen
thousand people were evacuated from
afghanistan to the uk
more than a hundred and five thousand
went to other countries
and many others were left behind
so what happened next
in this series we hear the stories of
some of those who were evacuated to the
uk their struggle to make it through
kabul airport what they left behind
and 12 months on where they are now
this is out of afghanistan for sky news
some of those who have spoken to us have
asked us to change their names
they're understandably concerned for the
safety of their families still in
afghanistan
but they do want their stories to be
told
we start with a family who had no idea
they were about to get caught in the
mayhem
my name is yusuf khan i'm 43 years old
and i'm originally from afghanistan
and i'm a british citizen my name is
shirbano and
i am 35 years old
and i'm a british citizen my name is
malalai i'm 10 years old
i was born in afghanistan
but i was here in 2001
and i was
a asylum seeker
it was the same time
the taliban was there so then the young
generation just only have two choices to
join them or run away
[Music]
after
we met and we met it's and then we moved
to leicester for some time
and in 2017 we
i just saw that we missed our family and
the life of afghanistan so we decided to
go there instead
we were just
staying normal life there with the joint
family with my other brothers my
daughter was going to school
even though yusuf was happy living with
family after four years he felt life in
afghanistan was becoming increasingly
risky it seems like
you were not safe taliban would have
picked you up or
asking for money or
saying we know that you're british we
are okay with you but you have to donate
that much money to this section also the
other criminals if they knew that you
are from uk or other places it's
happened with a lot of people
which i know that being kidnapped and
asked for rent some of
500 000 or 600 000 pounds
and some of them being killed as well
he decided they should return to the uk
i told them that i will leave because i
was the head of the family and the risk
is
more to me
and then told her i'll go to uk and find
a place
and then you both can come as well
and then i i came on normal flight on
14th
the plane yusuf was on turned out to be
one of the last commercial flights out
of kabul airport
i was fined that time when
my husband came to uk on that day we
couldn't see that the situation will get
that worse and then
on 15th of august when i see the news
everything was saying oh that city has
been
captured by taliban this city that city
and i was worried
[Music]
this is sky news at 11 the headlines
breaking news the taliban reach
afghanistan's capital cardboard
the taliban strategy of targeting police
and military compounds and cities in
different parts of afghanistan on an
almost day-to-day basis completely
overwhelm the security forces ability to
defend themselves
bit by bit those forces collapsed
the taliban claimed kabul 20 years after
they were targeted by the west
hardliners returned to the streets of
the capital of afghanistan i think
residents like shibano who'd been
preparing sunday lunch were utterly
stunned at what was happening we were
sitting and doing the lunch there was
like suddenly firing everyone was saying
the taliban came to
kabul and there was like a police
station when we saw them yeah there was
taliban
we was guests in our cousin's home my
cousin's home is here and our is here
here is a police station in the middle
uh when we go to there then everything
was fine
when we
go back to our home then it was taliban
suddenly everything changed there was a
lot of news but we were we didn't see
the news we were just seeing everything
live it was so close to our home the
police station
the police the police they take their
costumes
and there was so much and the whole
people there
ran off there
the taliban took over everything from
government buildings to checkpoints and
military vehicles often found abandoned
social media was overwhelmed by videos
of the taliban taking control
and celebrating when they took the
police station then they was happy with
the firing
then we were scared
and then i messaged him at that time he
was sleeping i think he was currently i
told him there is like taliban entered
to kabul and he also saw in the news as
well now i was worried and i called home
office here
and they say we'll call
they already issue a warning about
afghanistan
american british and other international
forces have been arriving at the airport
for days evacuating embassy staff
as the taliban breached the gates of the
capital tens of thousands of afghans
headed for the airport complex
soon all roads were jammed
people were terrified and desperate to
leave
over the coming days that desperation
saw people attempting to cling to the
wings and fuselage of transporter place
some held on until after takeoff but
then fell to their deaths on the runway
below
some did have a right to leave
but thousands more tried to join this
evacuation that turned more chaotic as
each day passed
[Music]
[Music]
and i waited about two days
and on that night like 10 30 they called
me
and said you can go to the airport but
it was late night and after 10 weeks on
go out and also the situation was
totally not safe
and all night i didn't sleep because i
didn't know what to do and how to go and
how to find the way and everyone was
telling me there is a lot
very russian very a lot of people you
couldn't go there and also the taliban
they do fighting and shooting
when we were thinking might be we will
go to uk or we might be killing the
airport
[Music]
shibano's fear was well founded
extra troops had been flown in to help
with the chaotic evacuation but the
deadline to leave was ticking away
troops had to be out of the country by
august 31st
thousands of people are leaving
afghanistan every day reports this
morning say uk flights may well stop by
the end of the week
shibano braced herself for what she
might face at the airport there were
many others who found themselves in the
same predicament
people like avzo
a 35 year old who would join the
military as a teenager i was soldier but
we will work with the british soldier
2020 and i start job as a training
officer with the afghan nppf national
protective police force our mission in
afghanistan was never supposed to have
been nation building
it was never supposed to be creating a
unified centralized democracy
when the biden talked we go out from
afghanistan and the other country as
well
we no believe that nato go out
because if the taliban control the
afghanistan
they will do
badness the same
like before 2000
in april 2021 after the withdrawal was
announced the british government opened
a resettlement scheme it's called the
afghan relocations and assistance policy
to give safe passage for the staff and
families of those who work for the
government or the british military and
support to resettle in the uk
had applied but like many others he
didn't yet have a passport and he didn't
think the taliban would actually win
when they left the background airport
it shocked us a little too we understand
let's happen
at the nato will go out he went to
collect his passport on the worst
possible day august the 15th when i go
to the
passport office
on that day
the afghanistan fall down
yeah it was happened like this
but
we no believe before that
he got caught in the taliban to take
over the city
we come out from unit and i under radio
i heard some provinces fall down
when we come to maybe
two or three kilometers the
road this closet and the people escape
from one side of kovalev all of them
they wanna come to another side of kabul
ten o'clock up to five o'clock i was
stuck on there
the
afghan national army and police was
finished
and the unit wasn't inside the couple
it was ruined by the taliban as well
same like my unit
my wife she called me really seriously
[Music]
back with shibano who we'd heard from
earlier
she's had a sleepless night she along
with her daughter and 17 year old nephew
are preparing to leave afghanistan
perhaps for good
i wear like normal
abaya which we wear in our country but
our friend they were going to airport
they said there is very rush and you
have to wear like short clothes not a
big one there will be like pushing and
pulling everything
when i spoke to the home office they
told me that you can't take any luggage
with you just like
one small hand luggage so i put my
daughter malala's
one clothes yeah because we didn't know
and also i took my nephew and he didn't
take anything any clothes because we
were very shocked in that time
i have so much things like school things
and my cousin likes to then i give her
everything
morning we come out from our home and we
just leave our home we didn't take
anything from there we just even we
didn't close it we call our relative
that they will come and see
if they need something
i miss my home now
my grandma was crying
and she was crying
we hugged and
like go
yeah
when we went to the airport there was a
lot of like thousand thousand people
there was like taliban and they were
shooting
the situation was very bad so they had
to stop everybody entering to the
airports
shibano and the children were trying to
reach the barren hotel where the british
had set up their processing operations
and this hotel was now protected by the
parachute regiment
the complex which looks like a military
base is reached by a narrow road that
runs along the side of the airport wall
the paris had placed two shipping
containers in a v-shape at the entrance
to try and control the movement of the
crowd
but the taliban had also set up
checkpoints along the entire length of
the airport road
the paratroopers now found themselves
face to face with the taliban the very
people they've been fighting for two
decades
the same time they're trying to deal
with thousands upon thousands of people
people was crashing when we were there
the four people they died i saw one of
them they put white clothes on it and
they took it to
take them outside
the desperation and fear came in waves
the crowd became agitated some people at
the front were simply crushed to death
the heat was intolerable and there was
no water many could be seen being beaten
by the taliban
we were scaring from the people and we
were trying to keep ourselves safe but
we were coming more out from the airport
and the people was trying to go in
even about five hours we were staying
there we didn't move about one meter
even my daughter she was carrying from
the firing and she said i don't want to
go and i want to stay back in kabul
because they will kill us
the taliban even on the top of the
barrier walls they said if you moved i
will shoot you that's why we couldn't do
anything
she didn't know what to do so she called
her husband yusuf now thousands of miles
away in london it was also a nightmare
for me as well because i was in current
in hotel i couldn't do anything
and my husband said i will speak with
someone and they will enter you to the
airport when i talk to them we have
three people they say okay you have to
pay us nine thousand dollars
i said i don't have that much money it's
too much what's wrong with you
but finally i think they decided 5 000
to everyone they will take 5 000.
after that there was a man and and they
come they told me come with us and we
will take you to the
right
day place make good amount of money
people give them cars and they take this
take me to get uh into the airport and
they bribe people yeah they take a good
good amount of money to just take you
through there
the taliban have denied these claims of
extortion and say they want to set
themselves up as a legitimate government
and they didn't do anything they just
took us to the door and they said you
can go inside and when i go there there
was also like shooting and they were
putting spray on people the ministry of
defense says uk armed forces did not use
cs gas grenades during the evacuations
and did not even fire warning shots at
that time it was like joined all the
military there was no space to to see
which side is which military but someone
told me in that time
keep your passport safe and if they put
spray that your passport will be damaged
when i saw the uk i just come
up my hand and i told them excuse me
excuse me sir and he looked at me
he said show your face and your passport
and then he said you can follow me he
was other side of the fence and i was
this side of gunsite there was a small
wall and it was a little bit hard
because i had also angel leg as well
first of all they took my daughter to go
the military helped me and i couldn't
even jump in
and i put my hand on military's hand and
just jumped there and after that my
nephew come that was the safe place they
said don't worry don't worry this is a
safe place
inside there was a
very mess-up and dirty place we was like
two o'clock we entered to that place
until 12 o'clock night we were standing
on the queue there was a lot of like
searching and then we entered there
there was like stones not any space to
sitting like car parking
1 30 at night
my daughter she was trying to sleep and
then i found a cardboard and put it on
the floor on the stools and put the bag
under her head and took out my clothes
and put on top
when it's night then it was so cold when
it's day then it was so hot we were
trying to sit with each other very
closely and we will get like a worm but
we couldn't my mom gave me everything
she said everything's fine
we keep going if we go back to home then
it will be so hard for us
and you have to go only far around
eventually they were taken inside the
airport complex proper
ten o'clock they called us to come to
queue another queue but there was very
sunny and getting hot and after one hour
my daughter she became sick she just
laid lay down on the floor
and
even my my sleeves which was out of my
hijab it caught sunburn and then they
called the doctor they didn't give any
medication but they said we will bring
you food
they tried to bring food but the people
who was on the front they just snatched
it yeah and took all the food fruits
everything in two days and two nights we
didn't
eat anything third day morning time
someone gave us like that much one lady
she brought bread from her
house and she gave it to us and just i
gave it to my nephew and daughter
because they were children i was
thinking they might i have the
you know the strength to keep myself
angry but not them
my mom was sleeping on ground yeah like
sit and sleep then i think she dream
if she's eating then
she did like
she was so hungry she said i dreamed i
eating the rice i'd eat a girl
and then another night come until
morning 8 o'clock that was our turn and
the immigration officer spoke to us and
and then they said okay you are allowed
to go in with the two kids
and then they put a number on our hand
like um 3000 or something they said this
is your ticket don't remove it
yeah and we try to keep it safe until
the uk
[Music]
still outside the barren hotel is
assault the 35 year old who had worked
with the british military
he's battling to get inside the heavily
fortified gates
by now he's worked out that the only way
to leave is to get inside the hotel and
enter the processing system if he
doesn't get in
he may never be able to go
when the car will fall down we skip to
behind the airport there was
many people on a continent today
after a few days when i entered the
airport
i met alex
he was a leader of the british group in
baran hotel
you say yeah
you need to go to uk and you can't call
your family while afzal and his son are
where they need to be the rest of his
family still have to get to the airport
but if he goes to get them he may
struggle to get back when they come near
to the gate they come enter to the gate
and i
i
move back out to bring my family inside
our contacted her back to the airport
and the people pushed me and i saw my my
son was inside there for the hotel with
my friends and
with the legs
and i was being with my family outside
there
and we receive a message to go out from
behind the door because we receive some
trade afsal's family are now separated
from his son
and things are about to get
worse a huge explosion mass casualties
people rushed to hospital
chaotic scenes in the midst of a chaotic
evacuation
for days there had been security
warnings that a suicide attack was
imminent at kabul airport the sheer
number of people the lack of checks the
absence of metal detectors and the
knowledge that islamic state were
actively operating in the capital all
added up to a frightening reality that
an attack could happen at any time
in the midst of the thousands a suicide
bomber struck in the sewage canal
between the baron hotel and the abigail
entrance to the airport it's no more
than a couple of hundred meters apart
at least 170 afghans were killed along
with 13 american marines i worried about
my son
many times when i spoke with him
he was crying and
that's no good for me and for my wife
and on the same time my small daughter
she was crying here
we lost him as well as well as being
separated from his son
afzal's daughter has now gone missing
she's been abducted they tipped my
daughter my son was inside the baron
hotel i was with my family outside
my small daughter the taliban talked for
three hours when i asked all the people
please my daughter i lost my daughter
a young guy
he told me
that guy
i saw him he took a small girl with him
but i know him he has a
shop in here and
he moved to this way
when i went to that man and i told him
you took my daughter he said okay and he
told her son
go and bring his daughter
when he
went
about
20 minutes they say okay
follow us my wife she was crying she
said my daughters we lost my daughter
the man
told her son
take some things
and we call
in afghanistan
like shirini
privately i take some money and i put
that money to
their
son
pocket and we received daughter
when i saw my daughter my my daughter
should not cry and she just feel like
this
afzal had finally got his daughter back
but now the family were outside the
airport and stuck in the chaotic crowds
again
he managed to make contact with the
british officer who had helped him
earlier after
25 hours or 30 hours
alex was
fined way and they put ladders
and wall
because in that time entering to the
airport was impossible
me with my family we entered to the
airport
everything was against us
just the people help us
we never
forgot that
back with shibano after three days and
two nights she her daughter and her
nephew were finally about to board their
plane ten o'clock we went to the
airplane yeah it was uh not the normal
airplane it was military airplane it was
so big
and we have to go in one line in
and they said the woman who was pregnant
with the kids or
disabled people on the set and other
people all on the floor and there were
just like specific places they like sign
it one for one one person and we don't
have any space to like move or anything
it was like
pretty touchy a long
things to hold and on the floor like
this we have to hold it like this then i
was tired then i
like leave it and i always go backward
ah like i was screamed
the hardest
thing was when it was taking off i was
feeling like there was no oxygen
and all the people was feeling sick i
tried to sleep and put my head on my
daughter's tummy but when i wake up i
see all the people was like unconscious
even the children and they were trying
to put water on top of it and
the military was trying to help them i
was thinking it is like you know the
night smell
she was missing from me
from for nine hours she couldn't answer
what's up direct call email
i try all things
her brothers over there my brothers are
trying to contact her
and i was so worried normally she would
contact me on whatsapp
but on that time i was checking every
second move i said come on give me one
text please just a sign that where you
are you are in dubai you are in kabul
you are in other country what should i
do who should i contact
and after that we went to dubai for six
hours and then it was commercial flight
emirates and it was very good flight and
and even we were coming here we didn't
know that we would go to london or
birmingham or manchester somewhere but
when we entered to the airplane then
there was like announcing this flight is
going to london then after that i told
them that now you are safe
and then suddenly i receive a message on
my facebook when i see she was her name
i said yes
so then i was so happy and so excited
and she was
very tired and divorced and she said i'm
here i'm fine the kids are okay
we all are tight and very very tight and
then i say oh thanks god
[Music]
they're heading to the uk with one small
bag of hand luggage
but what awaits
in the next episode of out of
afghanistan families tell us their
experience of starting a completely new
life
out of afghanistan is a sky news podcast
produced by anne-marie bullock and
presented by me stuart ramsey
archive is by simon windsor and sound
designed by will chalk
the editor is paul stanworth
[Music]